well now let me introduce our wonderful
student
interesting point
take your seat you can probably match
yourselves to them you're cutting email
students you can do it pranay is that
correct whisper not Renee Renee Jade
that's your cue to start is a senior
from Dallas he's pursuing a dual major
electrical computer engineering and
biomedical engineering he's a community
advisor for steve ur house that's our
green door hammer the cigar attorney may
may or the indian association the south
asian school association he's involved
in agra in the burgh or my favorite
organizations it's terrific he was on a
student homecoming planning committee
he's accepted a job at GE Healthcare
when he graduates congratulations pranay
Lydia Remington is a senior from Fairfax
Virginia she's majoring in public policy
and management she is the lead highland
ambassador with University Advancement
RC cheerleader number of the tri-delt
sorry she's currently evaluating her
options as they say in terms of whether
she goes in graduate school retains a
job he showed photic is a senior from
Pittsford New York she's pursuing a dual
major in statistics in professional
writing she's a dancer with our dance
suppose him a member of the Indian sue
Association as well and Kappa Kappa
Gamma sorority she's also an attorney
society scholar and she's accepted a job
with majestic research equity research
for the New York City after graduation
Jake Moen is from San Jose California
and he brought his own cheering section
he's a senior majoring in chemistry has
been very active on campus as a member
also the opportunity to sig ups here it
will see the secret handshake later on
he's the head mechanic of the Signet
sigep buggy team and I understand you
got two buggies and of the finest
congratulations to this terrific he's
remember the jazz ensemble putting play
excellent tenor eltham
he's a multidisciplinary mmm he's an
emissions tour guide good thing I liked
leading tours on the camry chemistry
student of Isaac Council and he's been
accepted in Carnegie Mellon's ph.d
program congratulations to Sarah shake
the senior from fremont california she
is also pursuing into a major in her
case business in political science she's
a member of mayoral Indian student
sociation and the Southeast Asian
Student Association member the political
science advisory council she received an
ax 2009 Alumni Association student
services deserve we only give out
actually fewer than a handful of these
very every year the recognition of
college Sarah is contributed the
University swati varsha I mentioned
before is from Burlington Massachusetts
and major in chemistry also as well as
tests aah science and humanities that's
the only worst thing that is actually
when you're speaking which is happening
to me before as I mentioned before
swathi 18 Churchill scholarship to the
journalist achievement as well as a very
Goldwater scholarship and she was also
nana kunning society scholar she saw him
water board and received a undergraduate
research grant and she'll be heading to
Cambridge University on her Churchill
and she's been accepted to study
material science
mi tease ph.d program material science
after so as you can see if very
accomplished involved please join me in
welcoming our wonderful ok I'm going to
start with a question and see how they
do and you're you're afraid of chai mean
any time with your questions if you
don't have any we have to put up with my
questions and I think they'd rather hear
yours let's start with this think of a
faculty number or an alumnus staff
member with whom you've had a
relationship of any kind preferably a
good relationship but then that would be
and tell us a little bit up once in wiki
everyone a volunteer first I'm buddy
ready to do that or so the person I'd
like to talk about is my research
advisor professor richard mccullough so
um rick is just like this guy some
random guy the parent stuff who is the
chemistry undergraduate advisor decided
to let me out what to do research does
she know is interested in it turns out
this guy was the Dean of the melon
college of science at the time two
months later promoted to be vice
president of research which is
is currently rick mccallum's beyond all
the stuff that he does for the
university starting his own company
making billions of dollars to invest
that always takes the time to be a
fantastic mentor to his students and
even to his undergraduate students for
just puttering around in lab and it can
easily pass off to a postdoc or graduate
student and I think it's very very
telling that I say that I have research
advisor who is the vice president of the
university but also one of my best
friends nice thank you smoking hard
elbert all right now you're ready right
man yeah I've worked with a lot of
different faculty members through being
are a through being CA or whatnot but I
think the one that kinda stinks me to me
the mostest we started this program in
three years ago called big questions
keep talkin is that is program a few
years ago called big questions in the
residence halls and we have a faculty
member actually come to the rest its
halls maybe once a week twice a week
depending on different things and we
just sit around in a circle talk about
big questions like what it's like what
is love what does it mean what does it
mean to call something home we talked
about a lot of different things a lot of
different topics and so we kind of
started the pilot program a few years
ago and we've had one pack remember a
canal coach who is a path to the physics
and works with a lot of the first years
and I've been to the first year dorms my
whole time here and just working with
him and just talking about life stuff
this isn't anything school related
anything I get to hear his perspective
on what does karma meet or
as does he believe it uncool punishment
stuff like that but you would never like
think about talking your professor about
like you go to a class you don't really
say here's my business professor they're
going to talk to you about unusual
punishment tonight like you don't really
get that experience anywhere else i
think that program has really worked
really well and so just being that close
with faculty number is great Lydia pull
up my covert so I think one of the most
interesting and intimidating professors
in my experience has been professor
fischbach who teaches dad's um which is
a social decision science course which
is a decision analysis and digit
decision support systems and um I
remember the first day of dads where he
explained that you can get a negative
infinity in the class and that means
that you base your confidence intervals
on how how right you think you're going
to be in the in getting the question
incorrectly so we were very intimidated
I've heard a lot about dad throughout my
whole time carnegie mellon i'm finally
to say i had to take it so um a coming
to his office you see a his desk is made
up of an old pilot Steve so it's very
interesting and he has a complete
different perspective than a lot of
other professors here at Carnegie Mellon
but he has been so on amazing at telling
stories and integrating his own light
into the class that it's not just about
um learning this course and about
deciding and um and everything that is
amazing about dads but it's also on his
life and he is connected students in
such an amazing way that is really
exciting great let me thank you you sure
so um my nose I think the best
relationship I've ever heard of a
professor is my advisor professor Oded
Meyer and statistics he advises all the
undergraduate statistics majors and I
guess what just makes them stand out is
that a mystic professor and advisor who
wants to teach straight from the
beginning a lot of advisors teaching the
higher level 400 level courses and
things like that he teaches introductory
statistics that the first stat class
that you will take akhirnya odd it's
probably going to be taught by him and I
think he just makes a huge impact that
way by putting the focus on everybody
not just people who are majoring in
statistics because almost every student
loan was it a go just one semester of
Statistics while they're here and
because of that truthfully I came here
as a math major and end up switching
into the statistics department primarily
because of him and I think just threw
out my experience with him as an advisor
like I would just be able to go into his
office and be like you know job or grad
school I think immediately was like job
I know that's right for you I know
that's what you want to do so just
things like that able to have him there
to answer my questions and then getting
to know him outside of Statistics
finding out that he's an amazing
classical pianist which I found out last
year um it's just really exciting to get
to know your professors like that
can be really helpful wesley shipp Jake
I saw our experience too I want this
actually difficult to pick a single
patient who you actually conducted on
campus because there's so many of them
for me there is one that stands out it's
what they mentioned my advisor Karen
stuff we're both chemistry major
chemistry advisor pacifica between pick
between my research advisor who works
with Rick and parent because they're
both been so supportive throughout my
time is concerned to graduate but Karen
in particular stands out because she is
one of those advisors who just it's just
so nice you can't even believe that she
has a person who is in charge of you
with a sense because she's more of a
friend than anything else huh and always
with her office she has got candy and
toys and all 21 just like laid out on
the office and whether it's a serious
meeting or you seriously spot some candy
she's almost under her door is always
open to that's one great thing on her so
you can spot your head and say hi what
time I got a bad grade on the test which
happens when I'd like to admit but
she'll email you be like hey I saw his
person to send you got bad grades I was
wondering if you're doing okay in that
class that's not the kind of personal
attention you get at most schools but at
Carnegie Mellon this you know par for
the course especially I can always
become CS it's in college a min but
everyone I've talked to has the same
experience and that's just fantastic you
don't get that kind of support I think
thanks Jim sir so I'm gonna be a little
selfish and say that I
nine and we'll go into specifics but
women friends said into this movie which
involves seeing you in love and it
wasn't about relationships on campus it
was about professors and how they
quantified love and how did they how do
they fall in love with Carnegie Mellon
University and we decided to find the
top niche research professors on campus
people that you don't run into on campus
by walking they went to teach you a
class people like red Whitaker who's the
godfather of robotic on campus and for
us it was an opportunity to meet
individuals that we don't get to me in
our everyday experience so take
advantage of it and we thought you know
it can be really difficult for us to get
into contact with these amazing people
in campus and all we did was send an
email and we quickly got responses and
we got to have these personal interviews
and put this movie together and if you
guys are all around tomorrow you can
actually watch it tomorrow at carnival
and essentially i watch it whenever I'm
running down considering the senior and
I have no idea what I'm doing when I'm
graduating and they gave the best if i
spelt light and they really really i'm
just connected with you and you know one
of those individuals was president cone
himself and you watch it you just do
figured that like you know they love
what they do they love printing emailing
and I love credit you know that's why
I'm to them and so maybe I will figure
out what it is I wanted to
and I don't know yet but it's it's a
really reassuring video and it realizes
that like you know what other campuses
you can't just meet the top research
professors by just sending an email and
a 22 million you can so i was really
beneficial for me I should have right
now you know it's not any better than
this just a couple of comments on this
first of all it's kind of open someone
would say oh the president he's the
coolest thank you for my little Mitchell
actually be cool yeah yeah I had a baby
for them the other but the other thing
is we do an exit survey of all of our
graduating students and we give them
some like 40 things on which to judge
the university and Perry as long as I've
been here the near the top usually
number two is how accessible professors
are and that's what you just sort I I
could not in terms of if you were to ask
me all the things you will like us and
eat for students to think of when they
think of a strength or a positive
characteristic of the University that
would be I'm just delighted to hear that
you say that and I didn't have to thank
for that
okay anyway you have a question you can
ask Jake them for them so you guys are
all seniors right there I don't want
scary but you're in your last few weeks
school gear man looking back the great
time to reflect so beyond this wonderful
education that you're taking away from
there what puts are in the top
experiencing that's great question but
the first person who responds repeated
sermon you ready to start we'll go this
way so my top experience that isn't just
you know the education that try to game
on has supported me and you know it's
hard to start because I have
but I think one thing is the community
that Carnegie Mellon is give
and people around me and everyone says
you know the relationships that you bond
in college or the relationships that
will last you a lifetime but it is so
true and it's very scary to think that
we have three weeks left and every day
I'm just like clinging to my friends I'm
clinging to the girls in my house
because they're all from different parts
of the United States some of them are
international students and I realized
from the individuals have graduated MIT
been my friends Carnival is suing me
because I come from California and my
friends all go to school in the
California everyone with the go to
school with is from California we're
almost like little California bubble
butt at Carnegie Mellon it is so
international and so am domestically
different that when i graduate i pick up
anywhere in the world and know that i
have a connection whether i had that
person in a class or if i had that
person through a like a program or
project or they were one of my great
friends I can go literally anywhere in
the world I can confidently say anything
that I know someone and that I think is
beautiful and it really excited about
that as well take traveling benefit what
I'll take away from Carnegie Mellon is
how do i phrase this the feebly not to
fear committing over committing myself
to something in particular and for me at
Carnegie Mellon that has been
undergraduate research I started to have
their graduate research Leo it's
something to occupy my time it'll be
but the bonded I've developed with my
advisor and my lab has been phenomenal I
absolutely love my research going to lab
every day is a highlight of my day and
I'm proud to admit actually when I go
when I traveled beyond away from
Carnegie Mellon need to pay more to all
know my team thereafter I'll carry that
with me just not to be afraid to dive
right in and really get to know exactly
what I'm doing and wants to know
everything about it so that just beyond
being a student I can be that top
research scientist and use that to carry
my career for I I would have answered
the previous to access Teen Miss person
I got to keep both the xhosa thankfully
but I guess the one thing if i look back
my experience carnegie mellon i would
take away other than the outstanding
education is probably the you got argued
on the state college i would argue
differently that the ability to live an
adult to be a grown person there's so
many skills you learned carnegie mellon
that you probably couldn't or in other
places like for instance time management
12 like for instance not be afraid to
try something new it's a very nurturing
campus in the sense that well to our
discussed the faculty and staff are very
accepting and accessible the sarah mitch
and all the people who come here are
very welcome people I the reason I
decided to come this because one night I
spent
it was enough for me to decide to come
here and that sort of environment
teaches you that it's okay to take risks
here's the kinds you can text in case
college it's time to learn them like I
said people will say oh this where
you're in college I stay carding about
this a better job than I think a while
to realize um I think the thing that I'm
definitely going to take away with me
the most is the fact that Carnegie
Mellon allows you to break stereotypes
and just coming out of a very preppy
public high school where there were a
lot of clicks and you kind of like had
to fit into a certain group and you were
kind of in that group for the entire
four years that you were there coming
here was the exact opposite like I could
be Indian and I could join a sorority I
could join dance or symposium even
though I hadn't danced since like the
third grade of them just things like
that just having these opportunities to
meet so many different kinds of people
and being so many different
organizations that may not really have
anything to do with each other but learn
things from all of them and I think
that's definitely the most valuable
this might sound a bit nerdy but so I
guess what I learned what I've gained
most about my experience at carnival is
the problem solving techniques that um
that I've carried with me throughout the
years and what I realized that I wanted
to pursue a more of a specialization in
health policy because sophomore year
sophomore junior year I decided that
that's something that we really need to
focus on and um it just so happens that
our government is is focusing on that as
well so um I guess that's when I go back
home I'm um I'm around my family and
friends I'm like let's solve this
problem let's go ahead and do this and
everyone's like you know like let's go
through this a little bit slower or like
and like no I'm ready to take this on
full charge a hat so um I I definitely
think that that's one thing that
Carnegie Mellon is does a really good
job with is um looking forward to solve
the problems and spearhead those those
kind of initiatives so I'm really proud
of being a part of that here and I'm
glad that Carney mom has taught me that
um first off it is scary it's going to
be scary and I think that's the first
thing that a lot of us feel when we
realized that we have three gigs here
but the best thing that didn't present
cohen responses to it is I'm scared that
I think about it I'm like it's gonna be
okay like there's no way that I would
have to work as hard as that work and if
there isn't gonna be on par and alert i
doing is what I came here I obviously
didn't know about it and I rose up to
challenge then so I can rise up to any
challenge it's one thing but what like
tangible like what have I learned it
stuff I do drink Spring Carnival I've
been a boost here for past two years
never in my wildest dream that I've
imagined be building stud walls and
frames and two-story structures and
something we're going to get do that
again like I mean maybe I can go do you
have
community or something like that he goes
back to those opportunities like the
opportunity to be out there on race day
a buggy and you know helping out the
mechanics are can something crazy like
that or putting on a second story to a
booth at 3am are like we've done crazy
suprising making a ship I mean like
there's a lot of just out there stuff
that I never would have imagined it
would be possible and the other thing I
guess addition to that is I never
realized how much I would love
management like how much I love people I
think what I realized here at kearney
moments I I go to class and then I come
back and I made into an asset to you
know that's why I've been an RA for so
long that's why I minute booty right I
realized I love working with people and
that's what I really that's what I want
to do and it's weird to say that someone
else noise the interview process through
for jobs and stuff I was just like one
work with people just just
something I get to work with Tina that
was my biggest thing and so you know
that's what I kind of realized through
my course here and it's not that
anything that one in the classroom but
just me doing all the other stuff that I
do around has made realize that skirt by
the way the sigep booth is fantastic
congratulations they really do very very
impressive so you like yourself to get
over the big way to check it out maybe
else have a question yes why do you do
it up do you think
and wasn't your first choice maybe and
like how did you weigh uh want to go
first pretty yeah sure um I'll be honest
it wasn't the first choice um I did
apply early I it's an interesting story
anyway i dint I was one of those
stereotypical kids I was like oh MIT
like that's where I gotta be it's going
to be amazing and I remember visiting I
visited a bunch of different campuses
and I visit MIT and didn't like it I
didn't like I make it an image in your
head like this give me the school it to
be awesome and I went there don't think
this is totally not right like it's not
a fit and then I remember visiting
Carnegie Mellon and I was like this
feels right like there's a campus it
kind of makes sense that's like secluded
it's his own thing but here's the city
and yadda yadda the only thing that was
drawing me back was oh it's a Pittsburgh
like what um my four years have
completely destroyed that myth it is by
far the coolest city to be it's awesome
and to steal ur championships way too
much so uh definitely wasn't first
choice but it always in the back of mine
just felt like the right place kind of
i'm an engineer I knew I wanted to do
engineering I always heard the card
evilness great engineering school but I
the biggest thing that just sold it for
me was orientation I went through
orientation I had no ifs ands or buts
about it after a week of orientation
there's no question like I think it was
the first time I met a lot of these
people during orientation actually um
but in front of the first I were sitting
around and then something came about
Star Wars or something like that
something completely nerdy and someone
else chimed in about it so I was just
like wow like not is a high school
you're just like I don't know I can't
talk about this
right and then you come here and you're
like a little hesitant at first and then
you kind of just dive in and someone
else joins then and at the end of the
day you're like talking about Star Wars
for two hours by the way it was the
right fit it totally made sense and so I
I tell this everybody I'm so glad that I
didn't get accepted my top choices or
whatever because I wouldn't have been
able to do all the things I get to do
here and get a great education and do
boot buggy and do RA and all the other
little things that we get to do because
I would've been too focused on school
work so alright so I'll be honest to a
car devo Melissa best school that I got
into so I'm from Virginia and I wanted
to I'm the oldest of five so i wanted to
get away from my family and so i decided
that up carnegie mellon would be a good
choice because um it was far away but it
was still close enough that I could go
and miss it and it wasn't UVA were all
the people from my high school work one
because I did an International
Baccalaureate so I decided that I wanted
a little bit of a change so um I went to
visit at Carnegie Mellon I completely
fell in love with all people here and
the campus that it was just a perfect
location so that's why I decided to go
green um I'll be honest to craigy mom
was not my first choice um but I ended
up being down two billion I think could
even Tufts and University of Michigan so
um and my older brother went to Tufts so
I kind of had that drawing me to his top
set first actually um for me it was the
campus visit the hands down I remember
actually visiting all three within the
same week after I got accepted and and
literally like my mom and I are driving
home from Pittsburgh green email was the
last that later one or anything but more
pittsburgh on to rochester and and I was
like mom we need to order a hoodie I was
like I need a crane you melody TV know
your coin their hands like yes I got it
like that's the big thing in high school
you have to get a penny from with the
pleasure quite so um yeah we were
knitted the second came home and I think
for me just everything all the questions
I had to ask here while I was visiting
were answered perfectly like I said um
can I pursue writing and an math at the
same time they're like yes oh can I
pursue both of those and my hobby and
music they said yes um and so just
things like that just everything was
just answered perfectly and everything
that I wanted to do I knew that I would
be able to do here and excel at it here
I had similar experience at one else i
apply I did the college the college game
I applied to like way too many schools
probably and I have strong down the
history with Duke and I thank goodness i
did in their excel thing who have been a
very good fit personally I so I got all
high schools and my parents pride have
to send me on overnight trips to all
these schools that was great thing is I
got kind of untamed or sprint untainted
perspective and Carnegie Mellon's like
the definitely stand out her I came here
right away and that I didn't have a
place to stay on campus eiq sleeping
back weekends like almost the next day
so I just had hotel downtown Pittsburgh
which could be a little today but I just
decided to go walk around conversations
homes people
I took my cheese steak and then here the
next day there was one of those days
like today just it's like extra card
perfect it's just incredible and that's
like us nice i started access like
beginning they have a great day because
i stay with this guy he was kind of an
oddball but he lived in part my
friendship where the cracker dorm says i
think i've been renovated but the rooms
were tiny so I was always in the lounge
all the time and the RA for this floor
was this amazing person his name is
Jorge Jorge Chavez and he was a senior
chemistry major that he was majoring
green chemistry which was what I want to
do he had all his research pretty much
everything I asked him about like what i
want to do I do that too wow I wanna be
like you he slightly achieved then
George had died and so he kind of
convinced me and then like the guy who I
was staying with his reviews on crew and
I was like routine so they're like let's
check out in the morning and then like
they were all bored sitting around night
and then I'll fair some homework
surprisingly and they're like yeah let's
go to a brownies parties what's that and
literally the kids tomorrow instead of a
box of brands which my mom does thanks
mom they would just go eat all this
guy's mom's brownies and they were
delicious and they let's talk around
like sit around talking about in there
any things like Star Wars of course and
that's how I knew it was like confess
for maintenance i fell it at home right
away and it was a really great trip and
it just instant comparison to the other
schools i visited there was their toys
so i didn't have a top choice i don't
know if you've heard of middlebury or
brown but they're going
into the mix the schools are all very
dissimilar so the drug to Carnegie
Mellon for me was that I could do all
the things that I could do at Middlebury
Brown plus some science and technology
and since chemistry was my main focus
but I was also interested like Misha in
some of the humanities are was really
big into writing an english literary
studies getting in touch into the
science and humanities scholars program
was perfect for me but even still
occurring on it wasn't exactly perfect
giving you a Pittsburgh but at the end
of the day a big risk taker so it being
in pittsburgh was actually kind of a
drop and even though i'm coming from new
england and it's burgas comparative
vermont Providence Rhode Island and I'm
a patriot staying on the steeler country
the fact that it was a risk and that of
something different and something
exciting and it might be an uphill
struggle was really exciting and
enticing for me
right so you guys were great after so
i'll keep it as short as possible and
the wonders and then I tell everyone
that I tell every student that wants to
decide between c'mon and love the
university is that at Carnegie Mellon
you are a name I am Sarah she at any
other university you want a number and I
stand by that bully especially when my
friends all go to different universities
at this school you are recognized by
your name from all professors from all
president Cohen those are name on you
read it off Oh is he knows our names but
cut the capability to make those
relationships you find at this school
and I realized that because the school
to student the teacher is from ratio so
much smaller here that I can go to my
professors door and it's always open and
that was so different for me and my
options at california where the
undergraduate population is 40,000
students and I all guys going to handle
that and I found the perfect niche here
as I think all of us have Thank You
number 82
it's a very good answer well of course
your time has come to an end or how you
feel but I could listen to these kids
all day you're so impressive we're so
proud of you and we know you will do
great in life we'll be watching I just
gave my commencement speech oh well do
it again yeah thank you very much for
joining us please join me in thanking